You just want to check
my arse in Dubai on a yacht.
-In a thong!
-In a thong.
No, stop it because I'm
trying to be professional.
Oh my days.
-In a thong, yes!
-In a thong.
Hi, I'm Gena.
I'm here with Chinenye, who
plays Viv in Sex Education
and here are
her Netflix Nine.
Sex Education season three
is on the horizon
after a long wait.
What are you
most excited for
people to see this season?
I think I'm most excited
for people to see
Jackson and Viv lead
the revolution
and make a positive impact
on the school.
And, also, I think
my favourite storyline is
Hope's storyline
because I think it's
so complicated and layered.
-She's an onion.
-Yeah, exactly.
And there are so many layers
to her.
Speaking of onions, I really
think the same about Viv.
How do you think
Viv's character has changed
from what we saw when she
was first introduced to us
last season to now?
I think she's become way
more confident in herself,
but she's also dealing with
a lot of shame.
She's battling with Hope's
visions of the school.
Viv is the
classical people pleaser,
but she knows internally
that this is morally wrong.
She has a new boyfriend,
Eugene.
She sexted him
for the first time.
Yeah, I'm sorry.
My boyfriend just
referred to my vagina
as a "lady flower"?
Dump him immediately.
I feel
she's developed with me.
Like, as I've grown up,
she's grown up.
One of the moments
where I probably screamed
the loudest
was when we finally
get to see Eugene.
I was like:
"Thank you to the writers.
Viv deserves…
Viv deserves Eugene."
Viv and Eugene.
I was so happy.
I was like: "Yes, Viv!"
It's like why can't Viv be
with Eugene?
-Exactly.
-It's normal, isn't it?
And they're both
really smart
and it just works together.
When you, sort of, read that
and you filmed it and stuff,
how did you feel?
When I first read it,
I was just like: "Oh!"
"Viv has a new boyfriend."
I thought there was going to
be a storyline
between Jackson and Viv.
Yeah, I did, too.
I assumed that, too.
So,
when Eugene was introduced,
I was just like:
"Nice. Good for you, Viv."
"You get your handsome guy."
But I was really excited
to see Viv get someone
that she really likes
and cares about.
What is it like
working with Kedar
and portraying
that friendship on screen?
Because one of
my favourite things
is that
it's an "unlikely pairing",
but, in terms of, like,
Jackson's character being,
like, a popular boy,
Viv's character being, like,
not interested in friends,
very studious,
that kind of thing…
But it works so well.
What's your fave thing about
portraying that with Kedar?
I think we have
such a great chemistry.
We really bounce off
each other's vibes.
I think Jackson and Viv,
what keeps them
coming together is
he has so many expectations
that are placed upon him
and, I think, so does Viv.
They find that
common ground together
and that's why they
gravitate to each other.
They have a
really special relationship.
Other than Viv,
who's your favourite
character on Sex Education?
I'm going to say…
Lily's character, yeah.
I think she's so odd and
just a quirky little birdy.
But, yeah, I really like
what her storyline is
this year
and she's definitely
dealing with a lot of shame.
What is a common assumption
that people make about you
that's not necessarily true?
I've received, like,
Instagram messages
and they're like: "You're
really smart, aren't you?"
And I'm like: "No."
I am illiterate.
I can't spell.
I don't know
what life is about.
I can barely count to five.
But everyone thinks
I'm really book smart
and that's
just not the case.
I'm street smart.
That's what I am.
What, for you, has been
your most surreal experience
as an actor after doing this
and, I guess, so far?
I think…
walking down the street.
I was going
to get my nails done
and I walked
into this nail shop
and then everyone just,
like, looked at me.
And I looked at them
and I was like:
"What are you looking at?"
-Yeah.
-I'd forgotten myself.
My mind didn't click.
I was like: "Oh,
they know me from this."
I just thought
they were giving me evils
and I was like:
"Bro, I'm ready to fight."
When my agent came
to my house
and delivered the news that
I was going to be
in the show…
I still get, like,
goose bumps from that.
I think that was the moment
I was like:
"Actually,
I'm on a Netflix show."
"I've booked a job!"
"Mum! I'm screaming now!"
And it's weird because
she was on the balcony
and she was just like:
"Ok. I don't know
what this is."
She was not fussed at all.
I sometimes even
forget myself,
because, obviously, I work
at Netflix and I watch…
I love Sex Education
and I watch the show
and I watch
all of your interviews,
so even I feel like
I know you all.
And so, then when I finally
get to speak to you,
I'm like: "I need to
just stop asking
as if I know their answer."
We're best friends.
What are you talking about?
Right. I mean,
I thought the same.
I didn't want to…
Exactly, exactly.
We're a unit.
If you could pick a day
to relive from filming
just one more time,
what day would it be
and why?
When me and Jackson did
the TED Talk day
and we were on stage
and we made up, like,
a little dance routine
before coming out
and we were getting,
like, really hyped up.
And we were just ready for
that scene.
I do this. I'm like: "Yeah."
I think that'll be a day to
remember.
Did you see, like, me doing
the DJ on the balls?
I absolutely did.
I absolutely did
and I appreciated
every moment of it.
I did, I did!
If that is not a meme,
I don't know what is.
What is a topic that you
could talk about for hours
and not get bored?
I think I could talk about…
film and TV
for hours.
Yeah,
I just think it's such…
There's so much
to talk about
and it's always changing.
And it's something
I'm passionate about.
So, yeah. Film and TV.
And, within that same,
I'm glad you said that
because…
My last question was
going to… Stop it.
I wonder what
your last question will be.
Let me hear it.
No, no. Please.
What is
your favourite Netflix show?
Oh. I don't watch Netflix.
No, I'm joking.
You can tell me your
favourite show in general.
I ain't going to judge.
Well, you will judge.
No, no. I'd never. Never.
Look. Ok, my favourite…
favourites:
BoJack Horseman.
Yes.
I think it's amazing.
Big Mouth.
Yes.
Obviously RuPaul's
Drag Race, everything.
I really love
What We Do in the Shadows
with Matt Berry.
So funny.
I May Destroy You,
of course.
The conversation about
consent, sex is just so big.
I can have this conversation
about film and TV
all day long
because I watch everything.
I've had so much fun
interviewing you.
Thank you so, so much.
These were
your Netflix Nine.
Amazing.
Thank you.
I had so much fun.
Shall we just do more?
Can we actually?
Because I was loving it.
I feel like we were really…
I went to Italian
for some reason.
Ciao bello!